mackenzie scott first appeared on the
forbes world billionaires list a year
ago
after her 2019 divorce with amazon
founder jeff bezos
her shares in the company were worth 36
billion dollars
this made her the 22nd richest person in
the world and the fourth richest woman
on the list
this year she's still ranked at 22 but
she's now worth
53 billion an increase of almost 50
percent
this is because the value of amazon
stock went up 64
but even though scott's wealth has made
the headlines so has her philanthropic
efforts in a december 2020 medium post
scott wrote she had given nearly 4.2
billion dollars
to 384 organizations in a period
of four months in her post she wrote
this pandemic has been a wrecking ball
in the lives of americans already
struggling
economic losses and health outcomes
alike have been worse for women
for people of color and for people
living in poverty
meanwhile it has substantially increased
the wealth of billionaires
scott's donations have helped 500
organizations across the u.s and puerto
rico
including historically black colleges
and universities
and the food bank non-profit feeding
america
she also has signed the giving pledge
which promises to give away at least
half her fortune to charitable causes
either during her life
or after she dies although scott's
overall rank remains the same
she is now the third richest woman in
the world behind
l'oreal heir francoise betancourt myers
who is worth
73.6 billion and walmart heir alice
walton
worth 61.8 billion